crucial question Beth did he jump before
he was pushed
well I would phrase it as he was given
the opportunity to resign on his own
terms before he was forced out but I
think the writing was on the wall
because two complaints were upheld and
the Deputy Prime Minister himself had
said if any complaint was upheld he
would resign and it's pretty clear that
since two were out of the eight that if
he didn't fall on his own sword in the
end the Prime Minister would have had to
wield the knife and get rid of him so
the way in which this was done in a way
was as beneficial to Mr Rob as possible
because the sequencing was he got his
version of events out first being highly
critical of the process saying that
complaints hadn't been dealt with in the
right way and the threshold for bullying
in the view of Mr Rob was very low and
then we saw the tally report as to what
the accusations were or what the
findings were and the prime minister's
very sympathetic letter to him so away
yes he would have had to go either way
but the Prime Minister did it in a way
that was as beneficial to his former
deputy as possible because that's the
question that Richardson that's going to
get asked would he have sacked Dominic
Rob isn't it yeah it's the question uh
that would have been asked I think in
the letter there's an implication that
he would of because he talks about as I
said in that report a government of
Integrity uh professionalism and
accountability look I think there's a
couple of arguments in this Mark the
PM's backers would say he is clearing
out the top table when necessary two
resignations one sack in someone pointed
out to me earlier today that that was
very different than how Boris Johnson
behaved when the former Home Secretary
pretty Patel was to have found to have
potentially breached the ministerial
code he stood behind her whereas what
you see from Rishi sunak is a different
approach but others would argue why were
these people in his cabinet in the fast
place if he knew as I've been told that
there were concerns around Dominic Rob's
conduct before he put him into cabinet
and made him his Deputy why did he do
that you know so there's questions about
you promised a government of Integrity
but from the outset you put people into
your cabinet that it has now
subsequently emerged fell short of those
standards so then there's a question
about whether the sort of Center Scandal
is following Rishi sunak around and I
think the big question really Mark and
the one that isn't answerable right now
is whether or not this damages the prime
minister or doesn't I think what is fair
to say is that for the right wing press
and his supporters sort of framing this
as an attack against uh you know in
transient civil service will appeal to
some conservative voters and backers and
it will give a narrative for some of the
press but you could also argue that for
his political opponents this gives them
a line of attack that Rishi sunak says
one thing he doesn't mean it he's not
strong he doesn't sack them he allows
them to resign and it's the same old
Tories to quote sirma today and I think
that going up to the local elections
what Rishi sunak has tried really hard
to do since the beginning of the year is
to get on with the job and try and act
on small boats and try and act on
waiting lists and you know trying to
push through reform of the economy and
what this takes him back to is the place
he didn't want to be which is the issue
of Scandal of infighting of Party
politics rather than getting on with the
business of government and I think the
question is in the local elections you
know how bad will it be for the
conservatives and will that weaken uh Mr
sunac I don't think this is necessarily
a fatal blow for him but it's on
comfortable to have to lose your Deputy
Prime Minister around
bullying not allegations to complaints
upheld when you promised as a prime
minister to do politics differently yeah
and just finally Dominic Robb I mean is
this
political career done do you think or
well I think they survived the
Afghanistan issue and you know he stayed
on holiday during the when the Taliban
took over does he come back from this
well I think there's a couple of things
to say about Dominic Robb I mean the
fast is you know that he is clearly not
going to just let this go and go quietly
and one civil servant that used to work
with him said rather Riley uh to me
today and I said what do you think about
his response they said well he's the
boxer and he's Come Out Swinging for us
we've just got to get on with the job so
I think that there's a sense that he's
going to fight this and fight his corner
to the dismay actually of the Civil
Service and I think if that continues to
Bubble along and it all get exacerbated
that doesn't necessarily help the Prime
Minister the other thing I would say
about Dominic Robb is he is in a pretty
marginal seat in Asha in Isha sorry and
there will be questions about you know
he's now out of government you know and
he looks at the next election does he
think he can hold on the third thing I
say about this Mark is when people fall
all on their swords and have a period on
the back benches it's not unknown that a
prime minister who is loyal to that
person tries to bring them back so I
wouldn't write him off quite yet you can
see that there is still affection and
respect between these two men despite
all of this mess I think for Rishi sunak
he will be hoping that there's no more
Scandal in terms of the conduct of his
ministers and those in his cabinet
okay Beth thank you very much